[Music]
drug purchases news
submitted by Joe is the coolest whoa
it's a pretty good statement I like that
newlyweds got so drunk during their
honeymoon they bought a hotel oh [ __ ] be
nice yeah they must be balling already
keep my [ __ ] immediately yeah
how did he even fall in a conversation
how do they do it so fast cuz like
they've done alcohol didn't wear off
they're just [ __ ] drunk and you're
signing papers and are checking their
credit whole time like crap
I mean buying a house or anything big
yeah it's a process it takes a long
[ __ ] time and you have to sign a book
of [ __ ] papers like this then you're
in a third-world country
this is what happened this so as they're
signing their super adrenaline this is
fun they start sobering up like I don't
know a free drink okay boom you know
what I like it again mystic beating them
over and over and over yes I didn't
there are first world wars in the
third-world country and the money goes
far and they're already wealthy elites
went by his [ __ ]
so they're from London oh they were
honeymooning in how do you say it again
it's an island nation hmm at the tip of
the Indian Ocean yep that's where I'm is
from oh really I thought she was just
Indian no she's sure helping surely I'm
Kayla it's a singer she's a singer
Demi is also a quarter I think yes Danny
short along key yep you're Demi yeah so
this couple here their name is oh she
does look like a nice skinny Indian girl
Gina is 33 years old
mark is 35 they got married in June of
last year they were honeymooning you'd
think that hairs real which one whose
hair color or here not the kind of color
of course not well he was way younger in
the I kind of want to go there now he's
beautiful that looks really like them
out eaves they were staying in this
hotel and so they ended up having a
whole bunch of drinks with the bartender
and then that's when the bartender ended
up mentioning that the lease was about
to be over over yeah okay it could end
yeah thank you there's so many wait a
minute and I just couldn't think the
spire okay you got it
close finish - all right reach an end so
the lease is gonna end and that's the
cry guys stop all right I am anyway so
this couple here and they ended up
getting drunk off a rum they brought up
the whole lease thing and then they were
like oh we should buy it cuz they found
out that it was about three cabinets all
it takes is three coconuts to size
coconuts and one palm tree there you go
it's about thirteen thousand two hundred
US dollars a year to like run it yeah
and for three for a three-year lease it
would cost them thirty-nine thousand
five hundred and seventy six I would buy
it yeah I know what a move guys told you
that's what black and crazy dude yeah
they drink and this is all after
drinking about 12 glasses of rum damn it
can drank yeah so they agreed to take
over it for about three years so then
that was like that initial thing right
like oh we should buy it with the
bartender so then they set up a meeting
with this elderly couple that they were
the ones that were leasing it out and I
had to bring these two other people in
with them to translate yeah to translate
because the couple are the the people
leasing and I was in speak English so
then that's when they were like haggling
and since this couple didn't understand
what was happening during the whole
negotiation thing they kind of like like
half in and half out this whole time
they're still drunk
no so that's that was about to get that
to that so they were sober in the
beginning but because any really and
that was happening in conversation they
just slowly started sipping more rum and
more on it oh you write that wrong yeah
then they ended up getting drugged
threatened during the actual like
haggling like the whole business part of
it yeah we'll buy it for 80,000 how
about that that's so funny so it's about
40,000 no fifty no six seven eight so
husband and wife is just trying to make
more one of each other I don't think you
know how this works you guys I know
exactly how it works I want it for a
million dollars yes by the time they got
back home their family thought that they
were idiots that they should have not
been doing that because they still owed
money from the wedding [ __ ] well at
least making a profit huh uh wait you're
skipping wave to the end so then they
found out when they were giving some
money like to pay for it they found out
that she was pregnant so we're like [ __ ]
now there's like a kid coming into the
big nother expense another one they live
in a very small set an apartment a black
community huh who said black oh you know
black minute I thought she said she
lived in the black community I was like
interested in a small flat okay and then
I said apartment apartment yeah so then
yeah they just felt like she says that
Gina said that she was already feeling
like a bad mother she felt guilty as she
wasted all this money yeah drinking
[ __ ] brown water probably pregnant I
think that's the biggest thing huh no I
was in like a media it was like oh yeah
later later they found out that she had
fun right yeah they start drinking after
you know to celebrate yeah yeah cuz they
spent about eight thousand dollars in
renovations and they've opened they've
reopened the seven bedroom
bed-and-breakfast that they've named
lucky beach tangle bingo bango
oh you see that bang-bang golly I don't
know Italian yeah yeah don't it's really
nice damn so they they are saying that
there's a steady stream of people
staying there and that but their lease
is only for three years
damn what's the ozark one that he did
the same thing the blue what you can't
lodge law you know if as long as they're
mmm they should be making a profit off
that [ __ ] don't feel bad well the cost
to run it is cheap though thirteen
thousand for a whole year
thanks for Lankan local prices too so
they're probably only profiting a couple
a little bit you don't know yeah and
there's also because like they don't
Cleo said they don't make that much
money so that's a lot of money yeah in
itself
well I don't know how much they make I
don't know what they do well if the
business is paying for itself then it's
not bad right
that's like that she would cost like a
million dollars to run out here you know
damn if I need a runaway someone will
run away to Sri Lanka just run away with
my five g's wonderful safe there Sri
Lanka
yeah is it is highly touristy though
okay and if you know how to dance didn't
get that's true I join like one of those
like Bollywood cruise I hope they do
that over there and it's not just India
cuz then I would I would well cruise
they don't like I would make money yeah
it's like it's like the kynges but then
the ball you do really know I'm making
this up oh no I'm making this up or if
you know how to milk a yak that industry
is booming over there they got yes I
think so
I thought it was like monkeys and she
wanted to say the word yet go I was
gonna say goat that's inauthentic good
motherless but mother let's go we need
to go back to another we need to go to a
different tropical island is do it
alright alright what if no caiman hello
New Zealand
Atlantis will do that in City Oh in
Kauai there is a hotel for sale it's
about six million or something like that
it's been around for like ages how many
were you telling us this building what
I'm saying is what I'm saying is okay
let's say we're all like maybe in our
60s we're still young enough to like
work we're not geezers yet no people
retire at 65
yeah but 60 is still young like you
could still move and work and in but
your kids are all like gone to probably
like they're all adults now right but
then we're like oh [ __ ] nothing to do
we're just sitting our dough let's say
we buy this spot and then do like a
bed-and-breakfast hotel kind of [ __ ]
like and then you know that Jamie Foxx
show oh yeah yeah but it'll be us but
it'll be like pawn shop all-stars what
kind of reality TV show but we're
running like a bed-and-breakfast hotel
restaurant
Monticello our customers stuff so we can
sell it at a pawn shop I know where's
the pawn shop no no it's like a reality
it's like a business family show that's
what I meant like the structure of the
whole thing so what if we do that you
guys down
no I want to rent the booth and I just
want to give advice and I don't want to
rent I don't want to do [ __ ] I just want
talk I could live you know ever since I
went to Hawaii I can picture my
stewart's kawaii yeah so I could picture
myself living in Oahu because Kauai to
Oahu is like Oahu to LA uh you know
saying like Kauai is country is [ __ ]
there's a [ __ ] ton of white people okay
it's it's country so I like [ __ ] closes
at 8:00 p.m. and then even if it is open
they just run out of food because they
just didn't make enough is it even way
more beautiful than Allah oh it's like a
postcard everywhere dude that's how
that's how pretty it is but I will say
this Allah who's the [ __ ] really I like
a lot a lot cuz it's it's a good mix
between city life and just open water I
only like North Shore know you got a
little West Side bro
way better than North Shore that's the
desert no but then the waters are weight
clear
like the Westside water is like
literally you you're 30 feet and you can
look at the bottom that's how cleared it
Wow yeah so it's just pretty website
that's where I like Honolulu like way
north of that yeah so it's it's super
super [ __ ] nice but yeah there's a
lot of the natives are there you see
where the locals live the locals sorry
Joe I'm not going I'm not investing you
you could have no I will pay for it you
guys just heard about we have to just be
your employees yeah what but it'll be
like Jersey Shore it would be cold
it doesn't have to be Kauai it could be
Oahu dude I could run the personal
training Department yeah I gotta be a
bellboy you could be the head chef nice
I'm serving whatever the [ __ ] I want I'm
the bellboy the bellboy collect you
you're not gonna record us oh yeah you
got to be in the videos yeah can we go
to Hawaii again we should go to Hawaii
at the end of this year are you down you
can type you can eat the tigers ready
sucks after November yeah I mean the
waters gonna be crazy but it's still
Hawaii it's called call caller it's that
cold like cocoa mix my nipples freeze el
they call it never gets a late call and
riptides los golf pros will just go to
[ __ ] the waves are strong yeah at
that time that's why they have this surf
competition yeah a hundred percent
that's on one side of the island right
isn't the opposite all the waves are all
[ __ ] up and indica jellyfish yeah you
gotta go during the time when it's like
really like the the last best month to
go through the summer or October is
toward the end and then we're doing best
wait you don't want to go back
well actually we went to in Thanksgiving
time that was a good time too
[Music]
[Music]